did you entertain crowd funding for part
of the budget I thought about it um I
felt I feel too successful I really
believe in crowdfunding in a lot of ways
I feel for it to be most successful you
need to have the support of everyone
involved and for me David's been in
beyond supportive like overwhelmingly
supportive of the project but he wasn't
a producer on the film he you know he
would say the Sioux he's up he wasn't
interested in the process he wanted to
let me go make it and I sort of felt to
run a successful crowdsourcing campaign
for it it would have needed his
involvement because I felt it would have
been sort of dissing genuine to be the
way to run a successful campaign would
have been like hey sedaris fans you want
to see a sedaris movie and it felt what
is sort of I didn't feel comfortable
asking him maybe he would have helped me
done a video I'm not sure but I it felt
wrong to ask him you know for me and I
felt without his support it felt sort of
wrong to run a campaign for it now that
there's a finished film that we you know
we've closed distribution so I bet if i
was doing a self distribution i would
consider it now that there's a finished
film and now that i have interviews with
david elements i can use with his
permission of course but but I feel like
it's each each projects its own and some
projects are meant to be crowd funded
and then this one just wasn't wasn't one
of them I didn't feel like I can engage
the community in the right way and also
we had some actors attached but they
ended up not being the actors in the
final film and I felt like we would have
needed to utilize them but I felt
uncomfortable with that because I didn't
have a working relationship with them
yet and they were you know slightly
bigger names that would ended up in the
movie just by the nature of who at the
time I cast then they weren't big
earnings and they got bigger names it
got too busy be in the film and I ended
up with a cast I could have only dreamed
of having anyway so I'm thrilled about
that but it felt strange to bring them
involved it just didn't feel like I
could do it the right way and I feel
like when they look at the really
successful crowd crowd campaigns sure
there's some outliers that go into the
three and four hundred thousand dollars
but I really feel like the most
ambitious you really should get you know
is it to expect is at the most you know
100 you know I feel like even the
canyons I think they ended up going to
like 130 but you're Paul Schrader and
Bret Easton Ellis who each have massive
loyal decades-long fan bases and even
then and they pushed a lot on that
campaign
you know they had which is an incredible
amount of money but that still wasn't
enough for me to make the film so I also
felt uncomfortable going out there and
be like give me a hundred thousand
dollars and maybe I'll be able to find
the other however much we need it it
just felt wrong for this project but I
hope I can do something one day that I
can make cheaply enough you know this
movie had to be shot on location it had
30 speaking parts it had you know a
different location every day all
exteriors just had things that naturally
made it expensive and but i hope to
something if I did something small if I
did a movie I could shoot on my own with
minimal crew and minimal locations and
here in Los Angeles I would totally
consider doing crowdsourcing that way
you